the strobing of a cuttlefish is
completely mesmerizing its skin quickly
flashing pulses of dark bands down its
body its body that seems to perfectly
hover in place this ability is so unlike
anything we see in our terrestrial lives
we can't help but be entranced by it how
can a creature change the color of its
skin so quickly and what does it mean if
it feels kind of hypnotizing that's
because it actually is cuttlefish are
the only animal that we know of to use
hypnosis to distract their prey allowing
the flashy Hunter to shoot out its
tentacles and grab its victim we tend to
think of octopuses as the top seop pood
of the ocean smart curious mischievous
and colorful but all those same
adjectives can be applied to cuttlefish
and then some cuttlefish are as smart as
an octopus and arguably more extravagant
when it comes to their color displays a
surprising ability considering they are
thought to be colorblind they share a
lineage with octopuses their last common
ancestor comes from about 100 million
years ago but are different in some
significant ways cuttlefish have eight
short arms and two long tentacles and
their eyes have a strange w-shaped pupil
and they aren't quite as jelly as an
octopus cuttlefish have their very own
hard internal structure called a cuddle
bone cuttlefish also evolved an
incredible brain thanks to spending
millions of years as prey for pretty
much everything some species even have a
larger brain to body ratio than
octopuses scientists have even trained
them to go through mazes other
researchers have found that cuddlefish
have a good enough memory to understand
the relationship between how much prey
they eat and how often the food source
will be replenished in other words
episodic like memory that was previously
only attributed to mammals and a few
Birds cuttlefish are a small But Mighty
ocean creature how are cuttlefish able
to match the pattern and color of their
skin to their environment when they
can't even see color and Beyond hypnosis
what is all that flashing for just how
smart are cuddlefish and are they
perhaps the superior seapod of the
sea despite their name and despite being
cute cuttlefish are not known for
cuddling cuttlefish are seapods that
live in tropical and temperate Waters
worldwide except the Americas and they
generally live in the shallows near
reefs or seagrass beds there are around
120 species of cuttlefish which
generally range in size from 15 to 25 cm
the smaller species like the flamboyant
cuttlefish are as small as 8 cm and the
largest species the giant Australian
cuttlefish can reach up to 1 m and weigh
over 10 1/2 kg but where exactly did
their name come from the name comes from
the old English word for them kudell but
Scholars aren't really sure where it
came from or what it might mean we've
also called them inkfish Seacat sea
sleeve or sepid at different times turns
out Humanity has a long history of being
entranced by these creatures going back
to Greek and Roman Antiquity cuttlefish
were prized for their ink which produced
a long lasting brown pigment used for
writing and coloring cloth in fact
that's what gave them their name in
those languages sepia like the color
sepia which is also the genus name for
many species of cuttlefish maybe it's
impossible for humans to land on a
perfect name for them because cuttlefish
are just so weird for swimming sea
creatures a major component of getting
around the ocean is having some kind of
buoyancy system for fish that's the
swimbladder for for larger animals like
whales a large store of fat provides
buoyancy but cuttlefish have an utterly
unique buoyancy mechanism the cuddle
bone although its name suggests it's
something similar to any of our bones
the cuttle bone is nothing like the
bones we have a cuttlebone has high
paracity and high permeability meaning
it has lots of small voids throughout
its structure but it also has high
stiffness meaning it can resist changes
in shape when being acted on by a
physical Force these physical properties
are generally in opposition to each
other usually materials become stiffer
by adding more material and becoming
less permeable and vice versa but the
cuttle bone has two main structures that
cause these properties to coexist the
dorsal Shield is a thick tough layer
that acts as the base for the Lamar
Matrix and the Matrix is the region that
looks like corrugated cardboard with
many layered Chambers this is all very
complex Lex and very strange why did
such a weird structure evolve because
all of these materials act together to
help the Cuttlefish regulate its
buoyancy while also withstanding
external pressure that increases with
water depth with this porous material
the Cuttlefish can control how much
liquid enters the cuttle bone so that
the ratio of gas to liquid changes based
on their depth and how buoyant they need
to be the more gas in the bone the more
they will float the more liquid the more
they will sink having this buoyancy
device inside them means it's much
easier for the Cuttlefish to be
neutrally buoyant than it is for either
the octopus or the squid who don't have
a bone like this in fact cuttlefish
spend more than 95% of their time just
chilling hovering with neutral buoyancy
but even though the cuddle bone can
withstand some external water pressure
it can't do so forever therefore
cuttlefish can't go very deep since high
High pressures over a couple hundred
MERS would crush their cuddle bone and
kill them researchers have shown that
the cuttle bone is pliant enough that it
wouldn't fail catastrophically if it
went a little too deep but they still
aren't adapted for high pressures so
even though there are deep sea squid and
octopuses there are no deep sea
cuttlefish they're stuck living in
coastal areas closer to the surface in
the case of the tiny flamboyant
cuttlefish and its cousin the paint pot
cuttlefish the cuttlebone is slightly
less useful as a buoyancy device these
species live in Sandy patches of the
Indo Pacific and barely reach 3 in or 8
cm in size meaning that their cuddle
bone is Tiny and that little cuddle bone
causes them to not hover very well
instead these two species use a strange
type of locomotion known as ambling they
use several arms and fins to make
leg-like stumps which they use to slowly
creep across the sea floor camouflage to
look like sand so that they can sneak up
on tiny shrimp crabs and fish this
camouflage helps them avoid detection
while hunting but if the flamboyant
cuttlefish is spotted by a predator it
turns off its camouflage so to speak and
uses the opposite approach to scare off
its Hunter Vivid flashy flamboyant
colors color capable fish predators are
suddenly startled by the instantaneous
change in appearance of the Cuttlefish
and this disrupts their attack SE quence
outlined in fluorescent yellow both
species also use pulsing bands of black
a pattern known as passing clouds such
vibrant coloration has led scientists to
wonder if the flamboyant cuttlefish
might actually be venomous much like the
blue ringed octopus experiments have
revealed Trace Amounts of the neurotoxin
tetrodotoxin or TTX in their flesh but
the rates of toxin in the Cuttlefish are
so low that it would be unlikely to kill
a predator
it's an ongoing area of Investigation
but even without the possibility of
poison the flamboyant cuttlefish seems
to be doing pretty well with their
alarmingly vibrant display and they're
not the only species to use color to
their
advantage a distinguishing feature of
cuttlefish is their ability to instantly
camouflage themselves in any environment
they settle in this is truly remarkable
because coral reefs are the most diverse
and complex visual environments on the
planet land or sea and cuttlefish can
look exactly like Coral seagrass sand or
Rock part of cuttlefish camouflage comes
in 3D cuttlefish have a unique feature
in their skin called dermal Pap they're
made up of erector muscles in the skin
which lifts bumps in the skin into a
variety of different shapes that can
match the surrounding 3D texture of
algae Coral or rocks and with this
changing texture comes mesmerizing
changing colors and
patterns first in the skin are the
chromatophores organs that cuttlefish
have by the millions these organs have
an elastic sack of colored pigment
granules which can be expanded by tiny
muscles controlled by neurons in the
brain as the muscles Flex the pigment
Sac expands horizontally and reveals
itself over a larger area sort of like
stretching a water balloon full of food
coloring but chromatophores are
generally only yellow red or brown and
cuttlefish clearly use more than those
three colors or color
combinations their shiny iridescent
comes from the iridophores which are
thin cells stacked on top of each other
that reflect light at different
wavelengths making them appear any color
of the rainbow depending on the spacing
of the reflecting platelets and on the
angle from which they're observed and
lastly are the lucor a different type of
reflective cell that makes their skin
look white which is one of the most Comm
complex
colors collectively these three types of
skin coloration enable cuttlefish to put
on dazzling displays and with Direct
Control from the brain this change in
skin color occurs in less than 200
milliseconds faster than the blink of an
eye and it's even more impressive when
you learn that cuttlefish can't even see
color their eyes contain just one kind
of color sensitive protein which
restricts them to a monochrome view of
the world so if they can't even see the
colors how on Earth do they match them
one possibility is that cuttlefish see
with their skin enabled by light
sensitive proteins called opsins that
have been detected in their skin but a
more recent theory proposes that while
cuttlefish don't see colors like we do
they might perceive them in a different
way through chromatic aberration this is
the phenomenon where different colors of
light come into focus at different
distances because of of the way
different wavelengths of light Bend
through a lens short wavelengths blue
light get refracted or bent more than
long wavelengths red light we've all
seen this happen with a glass prism for
us chromatic aberration is a nuisance it
sometimes shows up in photos annoyingly
or is why when you get your eyes dilated
at the eye doctor everything gets a
fuzzy rainbow outline but perhaps
cuttlefish use this phenomenon to their
advantage those weird w-shaped pupils
let light in from many different angles
enhancing the chromatic aberration
phenomenon they could hypothetically
separate Reds yellows and blues based on
their wavelength allowing them to detect
color by detecting differences in
blurring as Focus changes so rather than
seeing different colors as we know them
they are detecting different levels of
blur and cuddlefish have another
peculiar capability they can see in the
dark and dynamic Ally changed their
camouflage to different backgrounds as
if it was high noon with all the colors
available in a field study in Australia
followed by lab experiments at the
Marine biological laboratory in Woods
Hole scientists verified cuttlefish
abilities to instantly change camouflage
on different backgrounds even when light
was at its dimmest with only faint
Starlight available for humans and many
animals This Little Light would mean
they can't see anything so for a
cuttlefish to not only see but see well
enough to still match their background
is impressive by any comparison but the
cuttlefish's color changing abilities
aren't only useful for hiding some
cuttlefish seem to use them for hunting
for most cuttlefish hunting can normally
be divided into four distinct phases
detection positioning strike start and
prey seizure the detection phase occurs
when the Cuttlefish first notices its
prey the eyes then focus on the prey
prey and the Cuttlefish slowly turns its
body so that the arms and head are
oriented towards the prey and at this
point during the positioning phase is
where some cuttlefish like the broad
Club cuttlefish get creative it will
begin a Rippling strobe like effect that
seems to Mesmerize their prey making it
easier for the cuddlefish to get close
enough without the prey fleeing at this
point the tentacles begin pointing
towards the prey but they hold their
fire then once the Predator prey
distance is approximately one mantle
length the tentacles abruptly shoot out
with extreme speed getting their aim
right before they shoot is of the utmost
importance because once the tentacles
are released the Cuttlefish loses all
motor control of them and has no further
ability to readjust the aim or speed but
with any luck the Cuttlefish will snatch
their prey up striking like lightning
before the unsuspecting animal even
knows what what's going on hypnotic
hunters and master camouflages the
Cuttlefish use their color patterning to
survive in the Cutthroat competition of
the ocean but the usefulness of Rapid
adaptive coloration doesn't stop there
it's also crucial in another aspect of
their life
mating unlike most other animals with
large brains most spilop pods aren't
particularly social most of the time
they hunt and live alone
the main exception to this solitary
lifestyle is during mating and as
researchers have learned more about the
courtship behavior of cuttlefish they've
discovered something interesting in
several species it's not always the
biggest males who win giant cuttlefish
that live around Australia will
congregate for Mass breeding with
females sometimes being surrounded by as
many as 11 males the larger males will
put on elaborate displays to intimidate
other males and will also guard the
females so they can't be accessed by any
other potential suitors but some of the
smaller males use their changeable
appearance to their advantage in these
situations too for deception smaller
males will actually mimic the appearance
and posture of females slip past their
larger male adversaries who think
they're gaining another mate and the
sneakers then mate with the females
while the large males actually guard
them and surprisingly DNA analysis of
the fertilized eggs found that the small
sneaker males who impersonated female
cuttlefish were successful in about 60%
of their attempts about twice the
success rate of the larger honest males
a similar strategy is used by a
different species the morning cuttlefish
but they take the disguise to a whole
another level when a male morning
cuddlefish finds itself in a situation
where only one rival male is present
along on with one female the male will
split its color displays in half
straight down the middle for the side
facing the female the male will present
its normal male colors for the side
facing the Rival male it will display
female colors to avoid being perceived
as a threat it pays off to be a little
deceptive when it comes to being a
cuddlefish you're more likely to catch
your favorite prey for dinner to avoid
being someone else's dinner and to pass
on your jeans to the next Next
Generation and it takes a certain level
of intelligence to pull off a trick like
this which is something cuttlefish have
in
Spades one of the most intriguing
aspects of a cuddlefish is the way their
minds work scientists long believed that
only vertebrates like great apes
elephants and corvids could demonstrate
any form of complex intelligence and
they had two hypotheses to explain how
intelligence evolved in these organisms
the ecological intelligence hypothesis
suggests that the physical demands of
locating food and determining when it's
best to eat it like the ripeness of
fruit or the level of decomposition in
meat triggered the development of
intelligence in our hominin ancestors
the social intelligence hypothesis on
the other hand suggests cognition is the
result of living in a social group
whether that means dealing with
competition or collaboration cuttlefish
squid and octopus are all invertebrates
without an interior skeleton or spine
and they diverg from vertebrates more
than 550 million years ago so their
particular intelligence can't be
directly related to that of vertebrates
in these species are mostly not very
social which contradicts the social
intelligence hypothesis in the case of
these seapods researchers believe it's a
combination of needing to forage in a
complicated environment needing to avoid
being eaten by predators and needing to
fiercely compete for Reproductive
success that pushed the animals to
develop uncanny intelligence and the
Cuttlefish have an impressive number of
abilities that Mark their intelligence
the Pharaoh cuttlefish have number sents
the ability to distinguish between
groups based on the quantity within them
they have both short and long-term
memory and can adjust their hunting
strategies based on past experiences and
future
expectations researchers have
consistently found that spilop pods have
a larger brain to body ratio than fish
and some reptiles and that their big
brains are related to their visual
systems short and long-term memory and
their system for camouflage and
communication some cuttlefish also have
a larger brain to body ratio than
octopuses so does that mean cuttlefish
are smarter than their octopus cousins
it's hard to say both organisms have big
brains good memories the ability to
learn and excellent camouflage skills
they also show different types of
abilities like the octopus that carries
shells with it so it has a home or the
way male cuttlefish will disguise
themselves as females for mating
purposes determining which one is
smarter is ultimately impossible because
they have different bodies different
habitats and different behaviors what we
can say for sure is that all the seapods
are a lot smarter than we once gave them
credit for despite Fierce e iCal
competition climate variations fishing
pressure and pollution the Cuttlefish
lineage has managed to survive more than
100 million years and is still doing
well in many parts of the world so maybe
if there's a lesson to be learned from
them it's this don't be afraid to be a
little weird or maybe a little sneaky
there's something truly beautiful about
pondering the complexity of evolution
throughout the billions of years life
has existed on this planet how a single
cell becomes many reproducing mutating
giving rise to the sponges worms and
Jellyfish the invertebrates and the
vertebrates the spilop pods birds
reptiles mammals and eventually us there
have been so many pivotal moments during
the course of evolution that resulted in
the world we know today and these
moments are so fun to explore with the
free-to-play game called cell to
Singularity cell to Singularity is a
non-fiction game available on Steam IOS
and Android that takes you through
Evolution where you start as a single
celled organism and progress through the
Tree of Life each biological upgrade
brings you closer to engulfing an entire
planet with a civilization on the brink
of technological singularity the game
also has limited time events that run
weekly in one of those events the game
explores the deep sea where it features
the Dumbo octopus vampire squid colossal
squid and the Beloved giant squid
players can play the deep sea event from
November 10th to the 15th over the last
few weeks I've gotten so deep into this
game it's easy to play and honestly
really soothing with nice music and
satisfying progression instead of Doom
scrolling while waiting for an
appointment I now pull up sell to
Singularity and see how many entropy
points I've earned and use them to
unlock the next steps of evolution every
piece that you unlock gives you a short
description of that evolutionary moment
and reminds you of just how incredible
every piece of The evolutionary puzzle
is this science-based game also has a
side simulation in space where you can
learn more about the planets comets and
moons of the Milky Way with NASA
supported data and a side simulation
about dinosaurs featuring The
evolutionary history of prehistoric
creatures throughout the Mesozoic Era
come play sell to Singularity today
using the link in the description the
game is available for free on iOS
Android and steam by downloading the
game using this link you're getting a
fun new game while also directly
supporting this Channel at no cost to
you